instead of making your retirement goal
an amount of money make it a date if you
make it a certain amount of money you
will get into this habit of always
accumulating more and more wealth but
the whole point of retirement is that
you have enough to spend later should be
a date that you're setting where you
start decumulating meaning you make
income you spend 100 of your income and
you spend a certain percentage of the
nut that you've saved the idea is we
save it for our retirement and if we
never spend it then we traded the best
years of Our Lives for this nut that we
never actually get to which is why
bother and so you have to set a date
because at some point and the big fear
is what happens if I die and I run out
there's things called annuities that you
can buy that guarantee income until you
die it basically diversifies risk
against lots of people so that everyone
gets guaranteed money until they die and
so you can even forfeit a portion of
your nut so that you always have your
basic needs covered and then you can
spend it down to zero